congress is considering legislation to
create a new and permanent office to
investigate ufo incidents and related
phenomena one of the primary reasons for
the renewed interest is the possible
link between ufo sightings and nuclear
weapons including a few in our own
backyard as the i-team's george knapp
reports some of these close encounters
go far beyond mere lights in the sky
the connection between ufos and nuclear
weapons has been documented as far back
as the very first atomic blast the
trinity explosion in 1945 new mexico
since then hundreds of former military
personnel have come forward with reports
of unknown craft buzzing nuclear tests
atomic labs and missile bases a group of
former officers told about their
encounters at a washington news
conference in october of this year
investigator robert hastings has
obtained hundreds of pages of once
classified pentagon files about these
incidents and has personally interviewed
more than 150 retired military officers
about ominous encounters involving
nuclear weapons ufos have routinely
monitored our nuclear weapons going back
decades the national security
implications are a major reason former
senate majority leader harry reid
co-sponsored a once-secret ufo
investigation overseen by the dia but
the ufo nukes connection is much
stranger than mere unknown craft in the
sky
on the outskirts of las vegas an obscure
part of the nellis air force base range
designated area 2 has for decades been a
reputed repository for nuclear warheads
as many as 200 nukes are said to be
stored in area 2's bunkers three layers
of heavily armed air force security
teams patrol the area 24 7 watching for
any attempted intrusions so on two
occasions we had an alert that was
called where
there was
unidentified flying object
over area two this former security
officer says intrusions didn't only
happen in the sky there were multiple
incidents of bizarre shadow people seen
in and around area 2 including one
dramatic incident from 1991 when
security teams were on high alert this
person was never found
um you know but the
the the airmen that that had seen this
this person
described them as being really tall
like seven foot
uh and like i said
moving very fast it was you know it was
very strange so when i got there i was
straight security another area two
security officer chris cabrera heard the
stories of shadow people but didn't know
if they were real until he had his own
encounter and when i turned around there
was this black mass
form i don't know what you would call it
it looked like uh
i don't even know how to describe it
like
like it looked like a person but it
didn't have definitive like shape of a
head
like a vague like a mist or something
it was black it was like like a dark
blob but it had like a rounded top like
a head almost and almost like a shoulder
as with the ufo incidents the sightings
of dark unknown intruders were taken
seriously at the time officers were on
alert as they searched area two but
never found a trace of the running
figures their commanders told them that
quote it never happened investigator
robert hastings says similar bizarre
incidents have been reported at multiple
nuclear bases and none of the mystery
encounters either in the sky or on the
ground have ever been solved george
knapp 8 news now